Thanks for coming on the geology.
Um,
that's a good name.
I was a great name.
I appreciate it.
Uh,
yeah.
So like how,
how's life,
how's everything going on lately?
Like that's pretty good.
Actually.
I'm living in San Francisco,
which is one of my favorite cities in the world.
A New York at the bay club second I think.
So they made me love my job,
love my apartment,
left my test.
Snake pet's name.
What is his name is Harris,
which is not very good name names.
He doesn't actually hit that same,
he's like super chill.
He's super chill.
Is he a killer saying uh,
no,
he is presently,
do you have mice in department?
In the faith.
Okay.
What will tell you just start working at Vittoria ever treat recruiter family
online?
Almost two and a half years ago when I first started working there.
Um,
and I don't even think I realized at the time that it was a company.
I had used their protocols and their African,
my application.
Yeah.
Especially in college to download stuff,
you know,
our college student.
And,
uh,
he reached out to me and said they were looking for a front end engineer on a
particular project and I just feel really excited.
I felt like there was that moment,
something incredibly special about the folks at this time.
It's just like a bunch of Quirky nerds who just love technology and love what
they do and nobody's really trying to show off for,
you know,
be trendy or you know,
they're in it for the right reasons and I just felt really at home then.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
And it's cool that like,
you know,
through this period of like Joe Montana,
which is,
can be really hard.
You,
you found a great position in that you seem to love.
Yeah,
that's great.
I personally like I was looking for jobs and I got rejected by law.
I,
and it hurts a lot.
I mean,
do you have any kind of advice for people who are looking for tech jobs?
Like how to like,
you know,
deal with rejections and like,
like what,
what,
what did you do?
Oh,
well definitely crying in the shower.
Um,
yeah is definitely going to happen and it hurts and insights and there's really
nothing you can do about it.
But you usually you'll find after like the initial period of being upset that
like,
it's usually like a,
you know,
it's like kind of a blessing in disguise.
They usually realize that like that was not the right place to be working.
Like either,
you know,
it we might not have been the right fit or um,
also like if somebody doesn't want you working there,
like that's not really,
you know,
it's like you don't want to date someone who doesn't want to date here.
I think the key is just to keep powering through to the top,
let it get you down too much because eventually you find the right sentence for
sure.
I think that's a great analogy.
It's like your day to day life at work.
Cause it's like a,
it's an open source protocol but it's a company.
Yeah.
As his money.
Right?
We um,
and we have multiple products as well.
It's not just the,
what we call a bit turned client.
Um,
so I work on the browser team and my friend had engineer,
although we're actually rebranding this spring,
it's surf that's going to be like super sexy.
Um,
but,
uh,
I referred him Tamir,
but I occasionally work in the back end.
Um,
it's basically a bit torrent,
but in the chromium browser,
so we've taken the chromium open source code and um,
we've been suited for some of our mentors and stuff in there.
And now you can fix the interim magnet lank and,
uh,
get a torrent right in your browser.
That's awesome.
Yeah,
there's a challenging,
where do you feel like it's something very true?
Um,
we'll book.
Yeah.
So,
which is part of why I left my job.
Um,
yeah,
some things are just super easy where it's,
you know,
uh,
doing some kind of a Ui work that's,
you know,
just very straight forward and simple.
Um,
and then sometimes like,
actually the thing I did today was going in and trying to change.
I'm trying to get our torrents today,
uh,
plane came to the chromium menu,
like the dropdown menu,
and you think that we'd be really straight forward except the chromium code is
not.
So you basically,
it's basically like a treasure hunt and you're trying to figure out that where
in the code you actually have to change some things.
So it's,
it's really challenging,
but it's also really fun and it's doable and it usually feels good when you
actually figure out how the pizza thing,
what,
what got you into programming in general?
Um,
so I moved to California and San Francisco in 2005 and I was actually,
um,
I was actually an astrophysics major and university,
so,
yeah.
So I'm,
so they didn't want to go into research or academia.
And so when I moved that to her that I was planning on going back to school for
mechanical engineering or something with a little bit more applied.
Um,
and while I was doing that,
I had a couple friends who are working on random projects that involve
programming.
They want it to make some,
actually youtube cause like visualizations.
Um,
yeah.
And so,
uh,
I,
I said,
you know,
what the hell,
I'm going to learn how to program it and I'll see if I can help out.
And then I just sort of never looked back.
I've just been burger.
That's awesome.
And it's one of the,
I think one of the sad things about silicon valley because there's not enough
women in programs.
It's awesome that you are,
do you have any like,
advice that you would give to like girls who want to learn to code or they want
to get into the field?
Um,
yeah,
definitely.
I would definitely say that first you have to sort of find something that you
want to build or make or just something that you're curious about.
Um,
doesn't have to be good.
It doesn't have to be,
you know,
useful.
It can even be something that someone did already that you'd want to learn
about.
So you just want to retell it underground or something.
Um,
it has to be something you're interested in,
someone passionate about and then you just sort of have to go for it.
Um,
the other bit of advice would be to not let anyone tell you you can't do
something or let anyone put you down.
And if people do,
cause you will definitely encounter people,
uh,
who are really good,
secure themselves and want to put others down and we them feel stupid and make
them feel bad.
Um,
consider just find any way to not let that bother you because that's,
that's huge.
I went into an interview once,
I definitely won't say where.
Okay.
And you can tell the guy who came into the room,
uh,
didn't know a woman from my resume and he took one look at me and he could just
see the look on his face.
Like it was just immediately like it went from like friendly to kind of set it
in under a second.
Obviously I can't prove that it was because I'm a woman,
but definitely will be like,
I feel,
you know,
10 years from now
or,
um,
well hopefully,
uh,
hopefully there's a cute guy involved
and like the same as I'm doing something.
Um,
maybe a little more science or physics.
I don't know exactly what it would be,
but,
um,
I actually really miss science.
And so if I can figure out a way to combine the two
without necessarily needing a phd,
and this,
I think a lot of hands,
I wanted to get rid of the space sex,
there's some thinking.
I pretty much need a phd.
Um,
so we are trying to find something along those lines where I can still keep up
with those interests.
That's awesome.
Cool.
Well
thanks for answering all these questions.
Thanks for coming.
Thank you.